I think general idea of whether living
citizens today are capable of imagining
the world when they're not there anymore
that seems to be kind of the hardest
bleep for the general citizenry to to
take the idea that there are many things
that they could do which would be very
helpful to people who are not yet here
and I'm not sure whether civilizations
ever been able to do that but there's
certainly a lot of impetus for that now
and so many issues come back to that
what do you wish to give up perhaps or
change in order and often very small
increments which would make a tremendous
difference but it is true that the
counter force is an extraordinary urge
deep within human beings apparently to
just look after themselves and fight
their way through and that's that sort
of the soar up from the jungle quality
so I think this is of course where my
profession seems to me to have
potentially some meaning which is that
the person who has allowed the
imagination to to at least take over
some of their life might be less likely
to to just think only of their their own
existence it's not guaranteed of course
because we don't know
we don't know whether people can change
yeah I think the biggest challenge is
going to be trying to well the
redistribution of resource there have
been encouraging signs which is that
some of the richest people have decided
that the length beyond an unheard-of
scale might be able to change some of
the most horrible situations
particularly African medical situation
so forth that's encouraging I think that
probably a much more radical idea of
redistribution of resources is necessary
and locally right now on a graph we're
going the other direction we're
certainly quite content with people at
the upper scale getting much richer and
people on the bottom disappearing and
there of course one could argue that the
lack of a primary truly genuine
spiritual religious impulse maybe one of
the reasons it's so hard to sell the
idea of distribution should
redistribution of resources
well just one is that it's not going to
be as dominant of force over the next
quite soon years I mean particularly
China and India and other regions of the
world have latent resource and power
which we've barely imagined and the
United States will not too long from now
begin to adjust to to not having the
kinds of controls that it has already
it's adjusted to being essentially a
third world economy but a much more
fundamental psychological adjustment
will have to take place and something
like that which England experienced
around the first the Second World War
and we'll see whether we have the innate
SIF civility to do as well as well I
would react probably just just in terms
of my own experiences day to day I think
that the medical of bureaucracy and the
people with no access to medical care is
probably as large a scandal as we have
and
some sort of ability to face that we've
made that we're in a terrible state
towards the rest of the world and we
very very very little respect and
probably the idea that it's what I was
talking about before in another context
that this country has a terrible hard
time saying that they were wrong or made
a mistake and a few times we've been
able to do it it's been very beneficial
but it is going to have to happen it
it's amazing so soon after the
withdrawal from Vietnam that we seem to
be bent on trying to string out and draw
out this very damaging process which
will will will damage it will hurt it
will hurt and kill people but will also
tremendously damage our psychological